Let's try using our knowledge of completing the square to solve this quadratic
equation. Now, we want the left-hand side of the equation to contain a square
so that we can take the square root of both sides. In other words, our goal is
to make the left side look like a perfect square. And the right side to be some
sort of number. Then, we could use our square root method that we learned
before to continue solving. First, let's move this positive seven to the other
side of the equation. We do this so we can start working towards getting a
perfect square trinomial on the left. And a number on the right. Now that we're
here, we want to add some amount to both sides of our equation. Remember, we
can only perform the same operation to the left hand side of the equation and
the right hand side of the equation, in order for our equation to remain
balanced. So, what amount will we have to add here to complete the square? And
since we add this amount here, remember, we'll add the same amount on the
right.